what brings you to tonwa doc the
computer dude kidnapped my son
what in the matrix hell is reading that
you used to actually play basketball
competitively when you were younger so
did this movie reignite your love for
basketball
yeah you see it's funny that the
parallels between this and
my real life you know because i also had
a dad
who also was my he was my p my p.e my
dad was also my pe teacher
my dad's a basketball coach he played
basketball my mom is 6'4 she played
basketball
and he definitely wanted me to be a
basketball player like that was supposed
to be
what i grew up to be as a professional
athlete a professional basketball player
and i and i decided i wanted to go a
different path i went the artsy route
you know
um so i definitely know what that's like
for like
your parents to have a dream and then
for you to have a dream but i also know
what it's like to have your parents
support your dream
and and be there for you and um and kind
of
guide your creativity and so i think all
of this is really about like
you know supporting your dreams it's
about teamwork and
and family and them and the the meaning
of creating
your family and protecting your family
and looking after each other
and yeah i don't know i just feel i feel
very lucky to be part of it and
um yeah a little basketball me
you know their their whatever other
alternate reality where i became
a basketball player you know i think
they're very happy
i love that you know they wanted you to
be a basketball player but here you are
playing you know one of the most iconic
basketball players in pop culture
lola bunny what was your first memory of
lola and how did you make her
unique to you you know and that's the
thing is like i can technically say that
i'm on a team with lebron like so i
still
write i did both if you think about it
you know
i i was just dad she did it successful
basketball player
um um yeah no it's um
i mean she's such an iconic character
right you know so many people have been
able to grow up with her and i think
i was just lucky that you know i got the
call
um to be a part of this and that you
know they felt that there was some kind
of similarity between lola and i or
at least you know what lola represents
and this kind of
new reimagining of of who she is and
and so i felt very lucky to to to bring
her to life
i feel like we are we're all really
lucky you brought her to life because
you did such a good job and and i love
you as lola
lola is one of my favorite characters
from space jam i'm obsessed with space
jam
and i also you know what i love about
station is the monstars and in this film
the goon squad so curious to know if you
had to put together
your own goon squad who from pop culture
would you have on your team
oh well obviously we gotta have lebron
on there um
because it's important um
because i actually did people ask me
this on another and i
actually i think i came up with a with a
brilliant strategy
it was instead of people from cultures
like my family members and
i said lebron for sure right we got my
mom holding it down right because her
favorite thing
is she's like i get the rebounds and i
can box people out that's what i do
i was like all right mom she can hold
that down we got dad he's the coach
right um and then my little niece who's
five
she can be the distraction right she's
adorable
oh look how cute and then boom you know
so i think
i i'm creating a dream team already
i love that this year is just it's so
incredible for you i feel like we're
living in the year of
zendaya you know you have spiderman
space jam dune coming out is there a
project that holds like the most
excitement for you
i honestly i can't i can't really say
they
are all really so special and different
like it's really hot it's like you know
they're all
have their own things that make them
exciting
um obviously this is one of them because
of just like the legacy that it carries
literally um but also you know dune
it's another legacy you know in its own
spider-man another legacy um
and then you know and then euphoria
which is like a completely different
thing
but we've built our own little little
legacy so
um i i am i don't know i'm just i'm
incredibly lucky and
i love what i do for a living so i can't
wait for people to see all the things
that
you know i've been able to work on
what'd you do to my son the only way
you're getting your son back is if you
and i play a little basketball
you want to play me and basketball don
cheadle what i love about
all the roles that you play is you
always have that total
buy-in always commit how did you achieve
that
with algae rhythm and what are you
playing to i
don't know um i mean
look it's on the it was it was on the
page first
uh and then you know working with
malcolm a lot
uh constantly throughout the the
shooting of the film just trying to you
know sort of attenuate
uh up down left right like who this guy
is and what he wants and what's his
what's he going after and how is he
going to go about getting it it's
something that we
constantly talked about and came back
and did reshoots and did additional
photography and did stuff in post
it was always trying to you know sort of
[ __ ] this
this his motivations and and what's he
after and how are we going to get it
what i also appreciate about you as an
actor is i feel like you always do a lot
of research and prep whether it's like
listening at music
or sometimes the costume helps you get
in character your character is like this
all-powerful being and it reminded me of
jeannie from aladdin almost was
jeannie an inspiration and if not who
was your inspo
well i mean there were you know i guess
genie would be a good comp
also in some ways i guess jim carrey's
the mask would be a good comp
and while we were doing this i was
wasn't
clear and i don't know that anyone was
clear up until
very late in the production maybe even
post
of how he was going to be represented
you know
i had motion capture dots all over my
face and all over my
my office so that at any point
it was possible to change my look change
my
body change my whatever i was but
ultimately i think i haven't seen the
movie yet by the way
um but ultimately i think they just kind
of decided to
leave it me and not not
do a lot until you know the finale about
about my look
so i never knew what algae was
ultimately going to look like we had
boards where
i had hair that was super geometrical in
my face had computer things going on at
the whole time
and i think for whatever reason is the
the studio decided no we want to see
don i guess wow that's crazy that it
went through all those iterations i
can't wait for you
to see the film it's so cool that you're
in space jam a new legacy
when i think back to the original space
jam i'm like a massive
fan of it why do you think people love
space jam like what do you think it is
about it
well you know i guess it's that mix of
in both of these you know
uh iterations of the story the mix of
the live action
and animation and classic you know
cartoon characters mixed with the goat
of their time you know that time
in his milieu basketball so
you know i think those themes are the
same i think where this one
you know diverts from that and in a very
to me
very pleasing way when i read the script
was you know it's a family movie not
just the movie you can bring all the
family to but the themes in it are about
family
and also it's a story where the three
main characters
all kind of want the same thing not
exactly going about it the same way but
they all want to be seen right they all
want to be respected they all want to be
recognized they all want to be able to
be who they are
and and respected for that and each of
them want that
uh and not until the end i believe if
it's still the way it was in the script
you know until until they have to like
figure out how to be a team to make it
all work out so
i think it was kind of cool in in rings
some bells if you want to do a deep dive
on space jam too there's deep stuff
there for you to look into
that's what we love about it so much and
and just like the goon squad too
if you were to put together your own
goon squad
who from pop culture would you have on
your team oh my god that's
i i should have this answer front loaded
because i get asked it
all the time i i i actually don't know i
mean
whoever they were they would uh have to
be at sort of an amalgam of all the
greatest basketball players that have
ever lived
right um and they would also have to
know how to cheat
i'll take it from here sam shoot the
ball
let's try that again shall we gabriel
you always talk about being fluffy
so what was it like you know playing
this tiny character
i know right uh speedy gonzales is the
fastest thing in my life
i i was i was honored and excited to uh
to be asked
to play the character uh speedy's very
iconic and he was a superstar and a hero
in our house
and he's always been viewed as a very
positive uh character so the fact that
uh you know i got the chance to
to play him uh uh also i'm the first
mexican to actually voice the mexican
mouse
so it's a big deal it's a really big
deal and uh warner brothers was very
supportive and uh
they appreciated the fact that i stood
up for speedy during cancel culture when
they came after him
and i jumped in there to save the day to
defend the mouse and my job
[Laughter]
how did you bring speediness through
your voice
oh uh well you know they they asked uh
do you want to do the original voice or
you know i was given the option do you
want to give it a more modern sound
and use your regular speaking voice and
i said well i don't want people to think
of me
i want people to think of speedy
gonzales and they say well you don't
think he's too stereotypical and i says
you have not
met my family so they said three two one
and go
and you know it's pretty easy to go from
this to all amigos
the fastest mosque in all mexico
and they're like wow that is amazing i
said i know i've been mexican my whole
life
it was easy i said but don't think that
just because i'm mexican i can only
voice the mexican characters i says
i do voices for a living i can do the
entire movie alone
i says you want marvin the martian oh my
oh my modulator
you want yosemite sam i like that rabbit
you want bugs bunny what's up doc you
want porky pig
get the picture i said you can fire
everyone right now i'll do the whole
movie
for half just validate my parking and
hook up some uh
honey buns i could have saved a lot of
money on budget what about lebron can
you do lebron
uh nobody can do lebron but lebron uh
lebron uh you know i
my voice unfortunately i can i can do
almost any voice but
deep voices are are difficult for me i
can't i don't have the bass
i don't have the bass to do it i got a
thick neck but i got no bass
in here you know the thing i love you
are hilarious one thing i love about
these films
are you know the monstars and the goon
squads if you had to make up your own
goon squad who from pop culture would
you would you have on your team
oh my god probably the joker
the joker would be a good one wolverine
would be a good one uh
deadpool and notice i'm going to just
like you know superhero characters i'm
more of a
marvel dude but the joker was a
here's a good one he's a good one right
there ah man i don't know
the joker would be incredible to have i
think that's that's a great goon squad
why do you think people love the
original space jam so much what is it
about space jam
i know for me uh the original film part
of it was actually filmed across the
street from my high school
in long beach uh they filmed it at blair
field
the the opening scene when the spaceship
comes down and they're they're playing
baseball
um yeah that's literally caddy corner to
wilson high school in long beach
and that was the day that i did not go
to school and so there was a lot of
extras in the bleachers
a lot of my friends were in the movie as
extras and i missed out
uh so you know i you know i always
wanted
like oh i wish i could have been in it
and i think it's cool that many years
later full circle
uh you know i got offered that part and
the chance to be part of this uh
you know this franchise and it is a
different movie by the way it is a very
different movie
the only thing that's the same is that
it's a basketball superstar
and looney tunes characters but it's a
very modern story and
a lot of heart and a lot of uh you know
i connected to it a lot because it has a
lot to do with the back and forth of a
father-son and i know i'm always having
these conversations with my kid
and i could feel lebron's frustration in
the movie
i love that that was full circle that
you're in this film um
do you think one-on-one speedy gonzalez
could take on lebron james
uh absolutely i think speed gonzalez one
on one would destroy lebron just because
yeah he's so much faster he's like he's
a lightning bolt he's he's really quick
you're about to lose your family in my
head
everything you love cedric
congratulations
what a cool role i'm curious did you
watch the original space jam and if so
what do you love about it
uh yes i did watch everything real
special
um and something i really loved about it
was you know warner bros combining the
coolest cartoon around that time
with the best player in that generation
um and
now they're doing it all over again tell
me about
the first day that you met lebron james
what was he wearing what did he say to
you
what was he like uh so i met lebron
at the chemistry read um at the lakers
facility
um and it was just you know something
chilly
some sweats and i remember you know
having that feeling of
me being super star struck and before i
went into chemistry when i had seen them
before i walked in the room
i had um went to the bathroom and
splashed water on my face just
like just like telling myself to calm
down and realizing that
this is really lebron james and
i remember going in there uh hot
remembering like
how cool he was and chill and humble he
was and he made it
really fun and you know easy for me to
work with him
that's so cool i'm like so excited for
you just like hearing you say it did you
you know your character is i feel like
loosely inspired by lebron's real son
brony who's an esports gamer did you get
to talk to bronnie about the role at all
um i i did talk to him but it wasn't
about the road um
but i i did see you know how they got
how they bonded
you know as a father and son and and you
know got to pick up some things you know
how he is with his real son or you know
how ronnie's with
you know lebron it was pretty easy you
know and
then the chemistry we had too we got to
um you know just like make it our own
really and he totally did as a young
actor must be so exciting to play
opposite don cheadle lebron james
what was it like working with them and
is there anything like you've learned
from them
working with lebron that's a dream come
true uh
you know like i said he's just such a
cool person
and he makes everyone you know he's
around feel very comfortable
and so getting to work with him was
really fun and then getting to work with
don cheadle
was mind-blowing um you know being a
young actor like myself and then getting
to work with
you know a veteran who's been in the
game for years um
you know getting to see how great he is
and how quick
he he is with you know the improv and
you know just how funny he is too and
how cool he was
uh the chemistry was great and you know
now we're like family now
so you know that's so cool i can't wait
for
people to see the chemistry between you
and and both of them what i love about
these films is always
you know is the goon squad and the
monstars so if you were to put together
your own goon squad or toon squad who
from pop culture would you want on the
team
man all all the goon squads
uh and
lola bunny in there yeah
what was the best any celebrities or any
other like people from pop culture that
you would want on your team
uh chris brown is really good at
basketball
um justin bieber is good at basketball i
actually seen him last night
which is pretty cool uh
who else uh man and then
why not uh nba players uh
i'm gonna go with
steph curry the greatest shooter of all
time
and then devin booker or no kevin durant
you gotta win this game and get our son
back
nico congratulations on the film i know
you are a massive fan of the original
as i wanted to know what do you think
people love about
the original so much like what is it
about space jam that people love it so
much
it's a good question i'm so happy to be
talking to you
um you know i i actually i i answered
this question
recently and i think that this is it i
think
that it's joy i think it's the joy of
the first one
that really captured our hearts and i
think that's why it stood the test of
time because
you have this champion you have this
goat right
um and you're seeing him be excellent
but you also have the looney tunes who
were
very near and dear in our hearts at that
time as well saturday morning cartoons
come on
um and so i think all of that combined
seeing this man
um fight for uh you know the future but
then also seeing this ragtag group come
together
and learn to appreciate each other and
love each other and work as a team
i think all of that was just joyful and
i think that it was also at a very
pivotal time in like sort of american
like society in history 1996 you know so
i just
i think everybody was coming together at
that time and i think that that's what
it did it brought us together and it
gave us joy
wow a plus answer i couldn't agree more
were you ever hesitant to take on the
role because you were such a big fan
you know what i i wasn't hesitant but i
was curious
i was curious i wondered how exactly
they were gonna do it how are you going
to make it relevant for today here 25
years later
so much has changed how is it going to
be important for today and i feel like
they
knocked that out of the park i think
they modernized this story to near
perfection
i really do i think it has everything
that you needed to have for it to be
nostalgic
for it to remind you of the original and
and pay homage to it but i think it also
has
so many elements that make it um
relatable
for today and make it important for
somebody in 2021
uh taking it i agree you know you play
lebron's wife
did lebron ever give you any direction
on set or tell you anything about you
know his real life
yeah give you any direction that you
could share with us you know what
he actually didn't um he didn't give me
any direction
i didn't give him any acting direction
we were actually
able to just be in this story together
which was really great and i think it
was important that
that's how we approached it that we just
said like here we are to tell this story
let's do it he came 110 prepared
so it made it easy it flowed really
nicely we had a great vibe
we certainly had a great vibe with
cedric and sierra and harper the actors
playing our kids
we just felt like a family really
quickly and really easily
so we didn't have to talk about that
kind of stuff we were just telling the
story
that's awesome what was it like working
alongside him and is there anything
that you learned about lebron that you
didn't know before going into this
i think he just just just like the the
movie itself i think he exceeded
expectations
because somehow he knew exactly
what it was going to require of him and
what the responsibility was going to be
and what and what that weight was going
to be like to carry
and he just came ready for it so it it
made it
uh it made it easy and i think it had a
lot to do with
with why it was so seamless also malcolm
lee the brilliant director malcolm lee
he
also made the process seamless and easy
um and just you know everybody involved
it was it was a really good group of
people too
so yeah what's happening
i look expensive malcolm
so many people love the original space
jam
myself included
what is it about space jam why do you
think people love it so much
i tell you you know it's the tunes
and you know putting someone like
michael jordan
out of his comfort zone right like you
know he's a very you know
uh practiced and and and and just to put
together her
guy you know and to see him you know uh
get made fun of or make up for
or be in uncomfortable situations i
think is
a joy for everybody and then but of
course at the end he puts his expertise
into the test and he triumphs and you
know similarly
in our movie we got these crazy tunes
and you know
putting lebron in these crazy situations
both as a cartoon and in live action
and i think people really want to see
that
speaking of crazy situations i agree one
of the best parts about this film is
when bugs bunny and lebron get to
interact with all these different warner
brothers characters
how did you pick and choose which ones
were going to make it into the film and
how they were going to be used
you know that that was one of the the
toughest things to to achieve you know
you know the tune gathering montage uh
because you know if you want something
that's going to be
funny uh first and foremost and he wants
something that's going to be kind of
quick
you know so we don't spend a ton of time
doing but so we went through numerous
iterations where
we make whole scenes out of you know
going to see you know like for instance
we
we had a thing where they they looked at
uh
thundercats you know and we had a whole
scene with that but like yeah but it
didn't really work it took too long
it was it didn't land this funny so we
wanted we were so many things that we
tried and then we finally landed on what
we landed on
um and i'm very grateful that it all
kind of worked out
it really worked out that's cool to know
that thundercats was supposed to be
um in there one thing that left me so
awestruck after i saw this film is the
animation i haven't been this awestruck
since i saw spider-man into the
spider-verse
what went into the process of animating
this film and what was like
the most aggressive difficult scene to
bring to life
you know i think that you know i had no
experience to deal with animation before
so it was all new to me so it's all very
challenging
to me but i think one of the most
difficult things was
making the the pencil drawn uh
hand-drawn 2d tunes into cgi tunes
you know because like you know the charm
and the expression
of the tunes and 2d is very different
than just you know
you have to get you can't just translate
it just automatically and make them just
as charming
so that took a long time to kind of you
know uh you know
mold and and and make you know you know
and to perfect so you know we got to
that place and i think you know it's a
to a great result you know so you know
all of it was difficult uh i would say
but you know we're very very rewarded at
the at the end i think
you're so right the fact that you've
never done this is so impressive by the
way but yes there's so much about like
what's in the eyebrows when you're
watching like a cartoon that brings that
charm
to life you know what was the most
difficult scene to bring to life
i can't think of anything that was like
really like you know like specific they
were it was all a challenge you know
what i mean like you know
it's the whole the whole game was like a
big challenge you know
there's so much going on there's live
action background actors
there's you know visual effect
background actors there's live action on
the court you know
with cgi uh characters and also with
mocap performers
so you know it was it was a you know a a
big big learning curve for me
um but at the end of the day you know i
had great support
from you know visual effects team and
ilm great support from my editor
uh great support from my animation team
and the studio my producers
so you know it all kind of worked out
and thankfully there were people in
place
that knew a lot more than i did that
would help me achieve the vision
who was the hardest looney tune to
direct
don't tell anybody but bugs bunny is
kind of a diva
you hear that for me but it's the truth
coming off the bench widely coyote
the machine is producing multiple wiley
coyotes
[Applause]
well that happened wow
we need a boost a secret weapon come on
man granny's out here having a martini a
hat time
kate is gonna hate